A good place to sample today's Turkish character is in Ankara.
A small provincial town just a century ago,...
...today, Ankara, with over 4 million people,...
...is the vibrant capital of a modern nation.
The city is a thriving example of Turkey's new affluence.
Energized by busy boulevards, prestigious universities and striking malls,...
...Ankara is contemporary Turkey.
If Turkey is more modern and comfortable with the West...
...than other Islamic countries,...
...it's because of its greatest statesman, Mustafa Kemal Ataturk.
This is the mausoleum and memorial museum...
...honoring the "Father of Modern Turkey".
Inside the museum tells the story of this amazing man,...
...whose career started as a military hero.
The memorial site is grandiose, with avenues of lions and formal guards,...
...giving visitors a sense of patriotism and nationalism.
The mausoleum itself crowns the site like a grand temple,...
...giving those who visit a feeling of reverence and respect.
Pilgrims from all corners of Turkey stand before the tomb of Ataturk...
...and remember the father of their nation.